all right today today we're going to
talk about spark spark say essentially a
successor to MapReduce you can think of
it as a kind of evolutionary step in
MapReduce and one reason we're looking
at it is that it's widely used today for
data center computations that's turned
out to be very popular and very useful
one interesting thing it does which will
pay attention to is that it it
generalizes the kind of two stages of
MapReduce the map introduced into a
complete notion of multi-step data flow
graphs that and this is both helpful for
flexibility for the programmer it's more
expressive and it also gives the system
the SPARC system a lot more to chew on
when it comes to optimization and
dealing with faults dealing with
failures and also for the from the
programmers point of view it supports
iterative applications application said
you know loop over the data effectively
much better than that produced us you
can cobble together a lot of stuff with
multiple MapReduce applications running
one after another but it's all a lot
more convenient in and SPARC okay so I
think I'm just gonna start right off
with an example application this is the
code for PageRank and I'll just copy
this code with a few a few changes from
some sample source code in the
in the spark source I guess it's
actually a little bit hard to read let
me just give me a second law try to make
it bigger
all right okay so if this is if this is
too hard to read is there's a copy of it
in the notes and it's an expansion of
the code and section 3 to 2 in the paper
a page rank which is a algorithm that
Google uses pretty famous algorithm for
calculating how important different web
search results are what PageRank is
trying to do
well actually PageRank is sort of widely
used as an example of something that
doesn't actually work that well and
MapReduce and the reason is that
PageRank involves a bunch of sort of
distinct steps and worse PageRank
involves iteration there's a loop in it
that's got to be run many times and
MapReduce just has nothing to say about
about iteration the input the PageRank
for this version of PageRank is just a
giant collection of lines one per link
in the web and each line then has two
URLs the URL of the page containing a
link and the URL of the link that that
page points to and you know if the
intent is that you get this file from by
crawling the web and looking at all the
all collecting together all the links in
the web's the input is absolutely
enormous and as just a sort of silly
little example for us from when I
actually run this code I've given some
example input here and this is the way
the impro would really look it's just
lines each line with two URLs and I'm
using u1 that's the URL of a page and u3
for example as the URL of a link that
that page points to just for convenience
and so the web graph that this input
file represents there's only three pages
in it one two three I could just
interpret the links there's a link from
one two three
there's a link from one back to itself
there's a web link from two to three
there's a web link from two back to
itself and there's a web link from three
to one just like a very simple graph
structure what PageRank is trying to do
it's you know estimating the importance
of each page what that really means is
that it's estimating the importance
based on whether other important pages
have links to a given page and what's
really going on here is this kind of
modeling the estimated probability that
a user who clicks on links will end on
each given page so it has this user
model in which the user has a 85 percent
chance of following a link from the
users current page following a randomly
selected link from the users current
page to wherever that link leads and a
15% chance of simply switching to some
other page even though there's not a
link to it as you would if you you know
entered a URL directly into the browser
and the idea is that the he drank
algorithm kind of runs this repeatedly
it sort of simulates the user looking at
a page and then following a link and
kind of adds the from pages importance
to the target pages importance and then
sort of runs this again and it's going
to end up in the system like page rank
on SPARC it's going to kind of run this
simulation for all pages in parallel it
or literately
the and the idea is that it's going to
keep track the algorithms gonna keep
track of the page rank of every single
page or every single URL and update it
as it sort of simulates random user
clicks I mean that eventually that those
ranks will converge on kind of the true
final values now
because it's iterative although you can
code this up in rapid MapReduce it's a
pain it can't be just a single MapReduce
program it has to be multiple you know
multiple calls to a MapReduce
application where each call sort of
simulates one step in the iteration so
you can do in a MapReduce but it's a
pain and it's also kind of slope because
MapReduce it's only thinking about one
map and one reduce and it's always
reading its input from the GFS from disk
and the GFS filesystem and always
writing its output which would be this
sort of updated per page ranks every
stage also writes those updated per page
ranks to files in GFS also so there's a
lot of file i/o if you run this as sort
of a sequence of MapReduce applications
all right so we have here this sum
there's an a PageRank code that came
with um came a spark I'm actually gonna
run it for you I'm gonna run the whole
thing for you
this code shown here on the input that
I've shown just to see what the final
output is and then I'll look through and
we're going to step by step and
show how it executes alright so here's
the you should see a screen share now at
a terminal window and I'm showing you
the input file then I got a hand to this
PageRank program and now here's how I
read it I've you know I've downloaded a
copy of SPARC to my laptop it turns out
to be pretty easy and if it's a pre
compiled version of it I can just run it
just runs in the Java Virtual Machine I
can run it very easily so it's actually
doing downloading SPARC and running
simple stuff turns out to be pretty
straightforward so I'm gonna run the
code that I show with the input that I
show and we're gonna see a lot of sort
of junk error messages go by but in the
end support runs the program and prints
the final result and we get these three
ranks for the three pages I have and
apparently page one has the highest rank
and I'm not completely sure why but
that's what the algorithm ends up doing
so you know of course we're not really
that interested in the algorithm itself
so much as how we execute arc execute
sit all right so I'm gonna hand to
understand what the programming model is
and spark because it's perhaps not quite
what it looks like I'm gonna hand the
program line by line to the SPARC
interpreter so you can just fire up this
spark shell thing and type code to it
directly so I've sort of prepared a
version of the MapReduce program that I
can run a line at a time here so the
first line is this line in which it
reads the or asking SPARC to read this
input file and it's you know the input
file I showed with the three pages in it
okay so one thing there notice here is
is that when Sparky's a file what is
actually doing is reading a file from a
GFS like distributed file system and
happens to be HDFS the Hadoop file
system but this HDFS file system is very
much like GFS so if you have a huge file
as you would with got a file with all
the URLs all the links and the web on it
on HDFS is gonna split that file up
among lots and lots you know bite by
chunks it's gonna shard the file over
lots and lots of servers and so what
reading the file really means is that
spark is gonna arrange to run a
computation on each of many many
machines each of which reads one chunk
or one partition of the input file and
in fact actually the system ends up or
HDFS ends up splitting the file big
files typically into many more
partitions
then there are worker machines and so
every worker machine is going to end up
being responsible for looking at
multiple partitions of the input files
this is all a lot like the way map works
mapreduce okay so this is the first line
in the program and you may wonder what
the variable lines actually hold so in
printed the result of lines but with the
lines points - it turns out that even
though it looks like we've typed a line
of code that's asking the system to read
a file in fact it hasn't read the file
and won't read the file for a while what
we're really building here with this
code what this code is doing is not
causing the input to be processed
instead what this code does is builds a
lineage graph it builds a recipe for the
computation we want like a little kind
of lineage graph that you see in Figure
three in the paper so what this code is
doing it's just building the lineage
graph building the computation recipe
and not doing the computation when the
computations only gonna actually start
to happen once we execute what the paper
calls an action which is a function like
collect for example to finally tell mark
oh look I actually want the output now
please go and actually execute the
lineage graph and tell me what the
result is
so what lines holds is actually a piece
of the lineage graph not a result now in
order to understand what the computation
will do when we finally run it we could
actually ask SPARC at this point we can
ask the interpreter to please go ahead
and tell us what you know I actually
execute the lineage graph up to this
point and tell us what the results are
so and you do that by calling an action
I'm going to call collect which so just
prints out all the results of executing
the lineage graph so far and what we're
expecting to see here is you know all
we've asked it to do so far the lineage
graph just says please read a file so
we're expecting to see that the final
output is just the contents of the file
and indeed that's what we get and what
what
this lineage graph this one
transformation lineage graph is results
in is just the sequence of lines one at
a time so it's really a set of lines a
set of strings each of which contains
one line of the input alright so that's
the first line of the program the second
line is is collect essentially just
just-in-time compilation of the symbolic
execution chain yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what's going on so what collect
does is it actually huge amount of stuff
happens if you call collect
it tells SPARC to take the lineage graph
and produce java bytecodes
that describe all the various
transformations you know which in this
case it's not very much since we're just
reading a file but so SPARC well when
you call collect SPARC well figure out
where the data is you want by looking
HDFS it'll you know just pick a set of
workers to run to process the different
partitions of the input data it'll
compile the lineage graph and we reach
transformation in the lineage graph into
java bytecodes it sends the byte codes
out to the all the worker machines that
spark chose and those worker machines
execute the byte codes and the byte
codes say oh you know please read tell
each worker to read it's partition at
the input and then finally collect goes
out and fetches all the resulting data
back from the workers and so again none
of this happens until you actually
wanted an action and we sort of
prematurely run collect now you wouldn't
ordinarily do that I just because I just
want to see what the the output is to
understand what the transformations are
doing okay
if you look at the code that I'm showing
the second line is this map call so the
leave so line sort of refers to the
output of the first transformation which
is the set of strings correspond to
lines in the input we're gonna call map
we've asked the system call map on that
and what map does is it runs a function
over each element of the input that is
in this case or each line of the input
and that little function is the S arrow
whatever which basically describes a
function that calls the split function
on each line split just takes a string
and returns a array of strings broken at
the places where there are spaces and
the final part of this line that refers
to parts 0 & 1 says that for each line
of input we want to at the output of
this transformation be the first string
on the line and then the second string
of the line so we're just doing a little
transformation to turn these strings
into something that's a little bit
easier to process and again at a
curiosity
I'm gonna call collect on links one just
to verify that we understand what it
does and you can see where as lines held
just string lines links one now holds
pairs of strings of from URL and to URL
one for each link and when this executes
this map executes it can execute totally
independently on each worker on its own
partition of the input because it's just
considering each line independently
there's no interaction involved between
different lines or different partitions
these are it's running if these this map
is a purely local operation on each
input record so can run totally in
parallel on all the workers on all their
partitions ok the next line in the
program is this called the distinct and
what's going on here is that we only
want to count each link once so if a
given page has multiple links to another
page we want to only consider one of
them for the purposes of PageRank and so
this just looks for duplicates now if
you think about what it actually takes
to look for duplicates in a you know
multi terabyte collection of data items
it's no joke
because the data items are in some
random order and the input and what
distinct needs to do since an e sirup
replace each duplicated input with a
single input distinct needs to somehow
bring together all of the items that are
identical and that's going to require
communication remember that all these
data is spread out over all the workers
we want to make sure that any you know
that we bring we sort of shuffle the
data around so that any two items that
are identical or on the same worker so
that that worker can do this I'll wait a
minute there's three of these I'm gonna
replace it these three with a single one
I mean that means that distinct when it
finally comes to execute requires
communication it's a shuffle and so the
shuffle is going to be driven by either
hashing the items the hashing the items
to pick the worker that will process
that item and then sending the item
across the network or you know possibly
you could be implemented with a sort or
the system sort of sorts all the input
and then splits up the sorted input
overall the workers I'd actually don't
know which it does but anyway I'm gonna
require a lot of computation in this
case however almost fact nothing
whatsoever happens because there were no
duplicates and sorry whoops
links to all right so anyone collect and
the links to which is the output a
distinct is basically except for order
identical two links one which was the
input to that transformation and the
orders change because of course it has
to hash or sort or something all right
the next the next transformation is is
grouped by key and here what we're
heading towards is we want to collect
all of the links it turns out for the
computation with little C we want to
collect together all the links from a
given page into one place so the group
by key is gonna group by it's gonna move
all the records all these from two URL
pairs it's gonna group them by the from
URL that is it's gonna bring together
all the links that are from the same
page and it's gonna actually collapse
them down into the whole collection of
links from each page is gonna collapse
them down into a list of links into that
pages URL plus a list of the links that
start at that page and again this is
gonna require communication although
spark I suspect spark is clever enough
to optimize this because the distinct
already um put all records with the same
from URL on the same worker the group by
key could easily and may well just I'm
not have to communicate at all because
it can observe that the data is already
grouped by the from URL key all right so
let's print links three
let's run collect actually drive the
computation and see what the result is
and indeed what we're looking at here is
an array of couples where the first part
of each tuple is the URL the from page
and the second is the list of links that
start at that front page and so you can
see the YouTube has a link to you two
and three you three as a link to just u
1 and u 1 has a link to u 1 & u 3 okay
so that's link 3 now the iteration is
going to start in a couple lines from
here it's gonna use these things over
and over again each iteration of the
loop is going to use this this
information in links 3 in order to sort
of propagate probabilities in order to
sort of simulate these user clicking I'm
from from all pages to all other link to
two pages so this length stuff is these
links data is gonna be used over and
over again and we're gonna want to save
it it turns out that each time I've
called collect so far spark has
re-execute 'add the computation from
scratch so every call to collect I've
made has involved spark rereading the
input file re running that first map
rerunning the distinct and if I were to
call collect again it would rerun this
route by key but we don't want to have
to do that over and over again on sort
of multiple terabytes of links for each
loop iteration because we've computed it
once and it's gonna state this list of
links is gonna stay the same we just
want to save it and reuse it so in order
to tell spark that look we want to use
this over and over again the programmer
is required to explicitly what the paper
calls persist this data and in fact
modern spark the function you call
not persist if you want to sleep in a
memory but but it's called cash and so
links for is just identical the links we
accept with the annotation that we'd
like sparked keep links for in memory
because we're gonna use it over and over
again ok so that the last thing we need
to do before the loop starts is we're
gonna have a set of page ranks for every
page indexed by source URL and we need
to initialize every pages rank it's not
really ranks here it's kind of
probabilities we're gonna initialize all
the probabilities to one so they all
start out with a probability one with
the same rank but we're gonna well we're
gonna actually you code that looks like
it's changing ranks but in fact when we
execute the loop in the code I'm showing
it really produces a new version of
ranks for every loop iteration that's
updated to reflect the fact that the
code algorithm is kind of pushed page
ranks from each from each P
to the page is that it links to so let's
print ranks also to see what's inside
it's just a mapping from URL from source
URL to the current page rank value for
every page ok not gonna start executing
inside the spark allow the user to
request more fine-grained scheduling
primitives than cache that is to control
where that is stored or how the
computations are performed well yeah so
cache cache is a special case of a more
general persist call which can tell
spark look I want to you know save this
data in memory or I want to save it in
HDFS so that it's replicated and all
survived crashes so you got a little
flexibility there in general you know we
didn't have to say anything about the
partitioning in this code and spark will
just choose something at first the
partitioning is driven by the
partitioning of the original input files
but when we run transformations that had
to shuffle had to change the
partitioning like distinct it does that
and group by key does that spark will do
something internally that if we don't do
any we don't say anything it'll just
pick some scheme like hashing the keys
over the available workers for example
but you can tell it look you know I it
turns out that this particular way of
partitioning the data you know use a
different hash function or maybe
partitioned by ranges instead of hashing
you can tell it if you like more clever
ways to control the partitioning okay so
I'm about to start
the first thing the loop does and I hope
you can see the the code on line 12 we
actually gonna run this join this is the
first statement of the first iteration
of the loop with this joint is doing is
joining the links with the ranks and
what that does is pull together the
corresponding entries in the links which
said for every URL what is the point
what does it have links to and I'm sort
of putting together the links with the
ranks and but the rank says is for every
URL what's this current PageRank so now
we have together and a single item for
every page
both what its current PageRank is and
what links it points to because we're
gonna push every pages current PageRank
to all the pages it appoints to and
again this joint is uh is what the paper
calls a wide transformation because it
doesn't it's not a local the I mean it
needs to it may need to shuffle the data
by the URL key in order to bring
corresponding elements of links and
ranks together now in fact I believe
spark is clever enough to notice that
links and ranks are already partitioned
by key in the same way actually that
assumes that it cleverly created links
well when we created ranks its assumes
that it cleverly created
ranks using the same hash scheme as used
when it created links but if it was that
clever then it will notice that links
and ranks are passed in the same way
that is to say that the links ranks are
already on the same workers or sorry the
corresponding partitions with the same
keys are already in the same workers and
hopefully spark will notice that and not
have to move any data around if
something goes wrong though in links and
ranks are partitioned in different ways
then data will have to move at this
point
to join up corresponding keys in the two
and the two rdd's alright so JJ
contained now contains both every pages
rank and every pages list of links as
you can see now we have a even more
complex data structure it's an array
with an element per page with the pages
URL with a list of the links and the one
point over there is the page you choose
current rank and these are all all this
information is any sort of a single
record that has all this information for
each page together where we need it
alright the next step is that we're
gonna figure out every page is gonna
push a fraction of its current page rank
to all the pages that it links to it's
kind of sort of divided up its current
page rank among all the pages it links
to
and that's what this contribs does you
know basically what's going on is that
it's a one another one call to map and
we're mapping over the for each page
were running map over the URLs that that
pages points to and for each page it
points to we're just calculating this
number which is the from pages current
rank divided by the total number of
pages that points to so this sort of
figured you know creates a mapping from
link name to one of the many
contributions to that pages new page
rank and we can sneak peek it what this
is gonna produce I think is a much
simpler thing it just as a list of URLs
and contributions to the URLs page ranks
and there's there's more there's you
know more than one record for each URL
here because there's gonna for any given
page there's gonna be a record here for
every single link that points to it
indicating this contribution of from
whatever that link came from to this
page to this pages new updated PageRank
what has to happen now is that we need
to sum up for every page we need to sum
up the PageRank contributions for that
page that are in contribs so again we
going to need to do a shuffle here it's
gonna be a wide a transformation with a
wide input because we need to bring
together all of the elements of contribs
for each page we need to bring together
and to the same worker to the same
partition so they can all be summed up
and the way that's done the bay PageRank
does that is with this reduced by key
call would reduce spike he does is
it first of all it brings together all
the records with the same key and then
sums up the second element of each one
of those records for a given key and
produces as output the key which is a
URL and the sum of the numbers which is
the updated PageRank there's actually
two transformations here the first ones
is reduced by key and the second is this
map values which and and this is the
part that implements the 15% probability
of going to a random page and the 85%
chance of following a link all right
let's look at ranks by the way even
though we've assigned two ranks here um
what this is going to end up doing is
creating an entirely new transformation
I'm so not it's not changing the value
is already computed or when it comes to
executing this it won't change any
values are already computed it just
creates a new a new transformation with
new output and we can see what's gonna
happen in indeed we now have member
ranks originally was just a bunch of
pairs of URL PageRank now again we
appears if you are I'll page rank
another different we'd actually updated
them sort of changed them by one step
and I don't know if you remember the
original PageRank values we saw but
these are closer to those final output
that we saw then the original values of
all one are okay so that was one
iteration of the algorithm when the loop
goes back up to the top it's gonna do
the same join flat map and reduce by key
and each time it's again you know what
the loop is actually doing is producing
this lineage graph and so it's not
updating the variables that are
mentioned in the loop it's really
creating essentially appending new
transformation nodes to the lineage
graph that it's building
but I've only run that Elite once after
the loop and then now this is what the
real code does the real code actually
runs collect at this point and so they
were in the real PageRank implementation
only at this point with the computation
even start because of the call to
collect here and I go off and read the
end burden we're on the input through
all these transformations and shuffles
for the wide dependencies and finally
collect the output together on the
computer that's running this program by
the way the computer that runs the
program that the paper calls it the
driver the driver computer is the one
that actually runs this scallop program
that's kind of driving the spark
computation and then the program takes
this output variable and runs it through
a nice nicely formatted print on each of
the records in the collect up okay so
that's the
kind of style of programming that people
use for Scala and I mean for for spark
went one thing to note here relative to
MapReduce is that this program well you
know and look looks a little bit complex
but the fact is that this program is
doing the work of many many MapReduce or
doing an amount of work that would
require many separate MapReduce programs
in order to implement so you know it's
21 lines and maybe you used two
MapReduce programs that are simpler than
that but this is doing a lot of work for
21 lines and it turns out that this is
you know this is sort of a real
algorithm to so it's like a pretty
concise and easy program easy to program
way to express vast Big Data
computations you know people like pretty
successful okay so again
just want to repeat that until the final
collect or this code is doing is
generating a lineage graph and not
processing the data and the the lineage
graph that it produces actually the
paper
I'm just copied this from the paper this
is what the lineage graph looks like
it's you know this is all that the
program is producing it's just this
graph until the final collect and you
can see that it's a sequence of these
processing stage where we read the file
to produce links and then completely
separately we produce these initial
ranks and then there's repeated joins
and reduced by key pairs each loop
iteration produces a join and a each of
these pairs is one loop iteration and
you can see again that the loop is
appended more and more nodes to the
graph rather than what it is not doing
in particular it is not producing a
cyclic graph the loop is producing all
these graphs are a cyclic another thing
to notice that you wouldn't have seen a
MapReduce is that this data here which
was the data that we cashed that we
persisted is used over and over again
and every loop iteration and so it
sparks going to keep this in memory and
it's going to consult it multiple times
alright so it actually happens during
execution what is the execution look
like so again the the assumption is that
the data the input data starts out kind
of pre partitioned by over in HDFS
we assume our one file it's our input
files already split up into lots of you
know 64 megabyte or whatever it may
happen pieces in HDFS spark knows that
when you started you actually call
collect the start of computation spark
knows that the input data is already
partitioned HDFS and it's gonna try to
split up the work the workers in a
corresponding way so if it knows that
there's I actually don't know what the
details are a bit it might actually try
to run the computation on the same
machines that store the HDFS data or it
may just set up a bunch of workers to
read each of the HDFS partitions and
again there's likely to be more than one
partition per per worker so we have the
input file and the very first thing is
that each worker reads as part of the
input file so this is the read their
file read if you remember the next step
is a map where the each worker supposed
to map a little function that splits up
each line of input into a from two
linked tupple um but this is a purely
local operation and so it can go on in
the same worker so we imagine that we
read the data and then in the very same
worker spark is gonna do that initial
map so you know I'm drawing an arrow
here's really an arrow from each worker
to itself so there's no network
communication involved indeed it's just
you know we run the first read and the
output can be directly fed to that
little map function and in fact this is
that that initial map in fact spark
certainly streams the data record by
record through these transformations so
instead of reading the entire input
partition and then running the map on
the entire input partition SPARC reads
the first record or maybe the first just
couple of records and then runs the map
on just sort of all I'm each record in
fact runs each record of E if it was
many transformations as it can before
going on and reading the next little bit
from the file and that's so that it
doesn't have to store yes these files
could be very large it isn't one half so
like store the entire input file it's
much more efficient just to process it
record by record okay so there's a
question so the first node in each chain
is the worker holding the HDFS chunks
and the remaining nodes in the chain are
the nodes in the lineage oh yeah I'm
afraid I've been a little bit confusing
here I think the way to think of this is
that so far all this happen is happening
on it on individual workers so this is
worker one maybe this is another worker
and
each worker is sort of proceeding
independently and I'm imagining that
they're all running on the same machines
that stored the different partitions of
the HTTPS fob but there could be Network
communication here to get from HDFS to
the to the responsible worker but after
that it's very fast kind of local
operations all right and so this is what
happens for the with the people called
the narrow
dependencies that is transformations
that just look consider each record of
data independently without ever having
to worry about the relationship to other
records so by the way this is already
potentially more efficient than
MapReduce and that's because if we have
what amount to multiple map phases here
they just string together in memory
whereas MapReduce if you're not super
clever
if you run multiple MapReduce is even if
they're sort of degenerate map only
MapReduce applications each stage would
reduce input from G of s compute and
write its output back to GFS then the
next stage would be compute right so
here we've eliminated the reading
writing in it you know it's not a very
deep advantage but it sure helps
enormous Li for efficiency okay however
not all the transformations are narrow
not all just sort of read their input
record by record kind of with every
record independent from other records
and so what I'm worried about is the
distinct call which needed to know all
instances all records that had a
particular key similarly group by key
needs to know about all instances that
have a key join also it's gotta move
things around so that takes two inputs
needs to join together all keys from
both inputs so that this all records
from both inputs that are the same key
so there's a bunch of these non-local
transformations which the paper calls
wide transformations because they
potentially have to look at all
partitions of the input that's a lot
like reduce in MapReduce serve example
distinct exposing we're talking about
the distinct stage you know the distinct
is going to be run on multiple workers
also and no distinct works on each key
independently and so we can partition
the computation by key but the
data currently is not partitioned by key
at all actually isn't really partitioned
by anything but just sort of however
HDFS have my distorted so four distinct
we're gonna run distinct on all the word
partition and all the workers
partitioned by key but you know any one
worker needs to see all of the input
records with a given key which may be
spread out over all of the preceding
workers for the preceding transformation
and all of all of the you know they're
all for the workers are responsible for
different keys but the keys may be
spread out over
workers for the preceeding
transformation now in fact the workers
are the same typically it's gonna be the
same workers running the map is running
running the distinct but the data needs
to be moved between the two
transformations to bring all the keys
together and so what sparks actually
gonna do it's gonna take the output of
this map hash the each record by its key
and use that you know mod the number of
workers to select which workers should
see it and in fact the implementation is
a lot like your implementation of
MapReduce the very last thing that
happens in in the last of the narrow
stages is that the output is going to be
chopped up into buckets corresponding to
the different workers for the next
transformation where it's going to be
left waiting for them to fetch I saw the
scoop is that each of the workers run
the sort of as many stages all the
narrows stages they can through the
completion and store the output split up
into buckets when all of these are
finished then we can start running the
workers for the distinct transformation
whose first step is go and fetch from
every other worker the relevant bucket
of the output of the last narrow stage
and then we can run the distinct because
all the given keys are on the same
worker and they can all start producing
output themselves
all right now of course these Y
transformations are quite expensive the
now transformations are super efficient
because we're just sort of taking each
record and running a bunch of functions
on it totally locally the Y
transformations require pushing a lot of
data impact essentially all of the data
in for PageRank you know you get
terabytes of input data that means that
you know it's still the same data at
this stage because it's all the links
and then in the web so now we're pushing
terabytes and terabytes of data over the
network to implement this shuffle from
the output of the map functions to the
input of the distinct functions so these
wide transformations are pretty
heavyweight
a lot of communication and they're also
kind of computation barrier because we
have to wait all for all the narrow
processing to finish before we can go on
to the so there's wide transformation
all right that said the there are some
optimizations that are possible because
SPARC has a view SPARC creates the
entire lineage graph before it starts
any of the data processing so smart can
inspect the lineage graph and look for
opportunities for optimization and
certainly running all of if there's a
sequence of narrow stages running them
all in the same machine by basically
sequential function calls on each input
record that's definitely an optimization
that you can only notice if you sort of
see the entire lineage graph all at once
another optimization that
spark does is noticing when the data has
all has has already been partitioned due
to a wide shuffle that the data is
already partitioned in the way that it's
going to be needed for the next wide
transformation so in the in our original
program let's see I think we have two
wide transformations in a row distinct
requires a shuffle but group by key also
it's gonna bring together all the
records with a given key and replace
them with a list of for every key the
list of links you know starting at that
URL these are both wide operators they
both are grouping by key and so maybe we
have to do a shuffle for the distinct
but spark can cleverly recognize a high
you know that is already shuffled in a
way that's appropriate for a group by
key we don't have to do in other shuffle
so even though group by key is in
principle it could be a wide
transformation in fact I suspect spark
implements it without communication
because the data is already partitioned
by key so maybe the group by key
can be done in this particular case
without shuffling data without expense
of course it you know can only do this
because it produced the entire lineage
graph first and only then ran the
computation so this part gets a chance
to sort of examine and optimize and
maybe transform the graph
so that looks topic actually any any
questions about lineage graphs or how
things are executed
I feel free to interact the next thing I
want to talk about is fault tolerance
and here the you know these kind of
computations they're not the fault
tolerance are looking for is not the
sort of absolute fault tolerance you
would want with the database what you
really just cannot ever afford to lose
anything what you really want is a
database that never loses data here the
fault tolerance we're looking for is
more like well it's expensive if we have
to repeat the computation we can totally
repeat this computation if we have to
but you know it would take us a couple
of hours and that's irritating but not
the end of the world so we're looking to
you know tolerate common errors but we
don't have to certainly don't have to
having bulletproof ability to tolerate
any possible error so for example spark
doesn't replicate that driver machine if
the driver which was sort of controlling
the computation and knew about the
lineage graph of the driver crashes I
think you have to rerun the whole thing
but you know any only any one machine
only crashes maybe every few months so
that's no big deal
another thing to notice is that HDFS is
sort of a separate thing SPARC is just
assuming that the input is replicated in
a fault-tolerant way on HDFS and indeed
just just like GFS HDFS does indeed keep
multiple copies of the data on multiple
servers if one of them crashes can
soldier on with the other copy so the
input data is assumed to be to be
relatively fault tolerant and
what that means that at the highest
level is that spark strategy if one of
the workers fail is just to recompute
the whatever that worker was responsible
for to just repeat those computations
they were lost with the worker on some
other worker and on some other machine
so that's basically what's going on and
it you know it might take a while if you
have a long lineage like you would
actually get with PageRank because you
know PageRank with many iterations
produces a very long lineage graph one
way that spark makes it not so bad that
it has to be may have to be computer
everything from scratch if a worker
fails is that each workers actually
responsible for multiple partitions at
the input so spark can move those parts
move give each remaining worker just one
of the partitions and they'll be able to
basically paralyzed the recomputation
that was lost with the failed worker by
running each of its partitions on a on a
different worker in parallel so if all
else fails spark just goes back to the
beginning from being input and just
recomputes everything that was running
on that machine however and for now our
dependencies that's pretty much the end
of the story
however there actually is a problem with
the wide dependencies that makes that
story not as attractive as you might
hope so this is a topic here is failure
one failed node 1 failed worker
in a lineage graph that has wide
dependencies so the a reasonable or a
sort of sample graph you might have is
you know maybe you have a dependency
graph that's you know starts with some
power dependencies but then after a
while you have a wide dependency so you
got transformations that depend on all
the preceding transformations and then
some small narrow ones all right and you
know the game is that a single workers
fail and we need to reconstruct the
Maeby's field before we've gone to the
final action and produce the output so
we need to kind of reconstruct recompute
what was on this field work the the
damaging thing here is that ordinarily
as spark is executing along it you know
it executes each of the transformations
gives us output to the next
transformation but doesn't hold on to
the original output unless you unless
you happen to tell it to like the links
data is persisted with that cache call
but in general that data is not held on
to because now if you have a like the
PageRank lineage graph maybe dozens or
hundreds of steps long you don't want to
hold on to all that data it's way way
too much to fit in memory so as the
SPARC sort of moves through these
transformations it discards all the data
associated with earlier transformations
that means when we get here and if this
worker fails we need to we need to
restart its computation on a different
worker now so we can be the input and
maybe do the original narrow
transformations
they just depend on the input which we
have to reread but then if we get to
this y transformation we have this
problem that it requires input not just
from the same partition on the same
worker but also from every other
partition and these workers so they're
still alive have in this example have
proceeded past this transformation and
therefore discarded the output of this
transformation since it may have been a
while ago and therefore the input did
our recomputation needs from all the
other partitions doesn't exist anymore
and so if we're not careful that means
that in order to rebuild this the
computation on this field worker we may
in fact have to re execute this part of
every other worker as well as well as
the entire lineage graph on the failed
worker and so this could be very
damaging right if we're talking about oh
I mean I've been running this giant
spark job for a day and then one of a
thousand machines fails that may mean we
have to we know anything more clever
than this that we have to go back to the
very beginning on every one of the
workers and recompute the whole thing
from scratch no it's gonna be the same
amount of work is going to take the same
day to recompute a day's computation so
this would be unacceptable we'd really
like it so that if if one worker out of
a thousand crashes that we have to do
relatively little work to recover from
that and because of that spark allows
you to check point to make periodic
check points of specific transformation
so um so in this graph what we would do
is in the scallop program we would call
I think it's the persist call actually
we call the persist call with a special
argument that says look after you
compute the output of this
transformation please save the output to
HDFS
and so everything and then if something
fails the spark will know that aha the
output of the proceeding transformation
was safe th th d fs and so we just have
to read it from each DFS instead of
recomputing it on all for all partitions
back to the beginning of time um and
because HDFS is a separate storage
system which is itself replicated in
fault-tolerant the fact that one worker
fails you know the HDFS is still going
to be available even if a worker fails
so I think so for our example PageRank I
think what would be traditional would be
to tell
spark to check point the output to check
put ranks and you wouldn't even know you
can tell it to only check point
periodically so you know if you're gonna
run this thing for 100 iterations it
actually takes a fair amount of time to
save the entire ranks to HDFS because
again we're talking about terabytes of
data in total so maybe we would we can
tell SPARC look only check point ranks
to HDFS every every 10th iteration or
something to limit the expanse although
you know it's a trade-off between the
expensive repeatedly saving stuff to
disk and how much of a cost if a worker
failed you had to go back and redo it
Bertha's a question when we call
that does act as a checkpoint you know
okay so this is a very good question
which I don't know the answer to the
observation is that we could call cash
here and we do call cashier and we could
call cashier and the usual use of cash
is just to save data in memory with the
intent to reuse it that's certainly why
it's being called here because we're
using links for but in my example it
would also have the effect of making the
output of this stage available in memory
although not on not an HDFS but in the
memory of these workers and the paper
never talks about this possibility and
I'm not really sure what's going on
maybe that would work or maybe the fact
that the cash requests are merely
advisory and maybe evicted if the
workers run out of space means that
calling cash doesn't give you it isn't
like a reliable directed to make sure
the data really is available it's just
well it'll probably be available on most
nodes but not all nodes because remember
even a single node loses its data and
we're gonna have to do a bunch of
recomputation so III I'm guessing that
persists with replication is a firm
directive to guarantee that the data
will be available even if there's a
failure
I don't really know it's a good question
alright okay so that's the programming
model and the execution model and the
failure strategy and by the way just a
beat on the failure strategy a little
bit more the way these systems do
failure recovery is it's not a minor
thing as as people build bigger and
bigger clusters with thousands and
thousands of machines you know the
probability that job will be interrupted
by at least one worker failure it really
does start to approach one and so the
the designs recent designs intended to
run on big clusters have really been to
a great extent dominated by the failure
recovery strategy and that's for example
a lot of the explanation for why SPARC
insists that the transformations be
deterministic and why the are these its
rdd's are immutable because you know
that's what allows it to recover from
failure by simply recomputing one
partition instead of having to start the
entire computation from scratch and
there have been in the past plenty of
proposed sort of cluster big data
execution models in which there really
was mutable data and in which
computations could be non-deterministic
make if you look up distributed shared
memory systems those all support mutable
data and they support non-deterministic
execution but because of that they tend
not to have a good failure strategy so
you know thirty years ago when a big
cluster was for computers none of this
mattered because the failure probability
was little very low and so many
different kinds of computation models
seemed reasonable then but as the
clusters have grown to be hundreds and
thousands of workers really the only
models that have survived are ones for
which you can devise a very efficient to
failure recovery strategy that does not
require backing all the way up to the
beginning
and restarting the paper talks about
this a little bit when it's criticizing
I'm distributed shared memory and it's a
very valid criticism I bet it's a big
design constraint okay so the sparks not
perfect for all kinds of processing it's
really geared up for batch processing of
giant amounts of data bulk bulk data
processing so if you have terabytes of
data and you want to you know chew away
on it for for a couple hours smart great
if you're running a bank and you need to
process bank transfers or people's
balance queries then SPARC is just not
relevant to that kind of processing
known or to sort of typical websites
where I log into you know I access
Amazon and I want to order some paper
towels and put them into my shopping
cart SPARC is not going to help you
maintain this part the shopping cart
SPARC may be useful for analyzing your
customers buying habits sort of offline
but not for sort of online processing
the other sort of kind of a little more
close to home situation that spark in
the papers not so great at is stream
processing i SPARC definitely assumes
that all the input is already available
but in many situations the input that
people have is really a stream of input
like they're logging all user clicks on
their web sites and they want to analyze
them to understand user behavior you
know it's not a kind of fixed amount of
data is really a stream of input data
and you know SPARC as in describing the
paper doesn't really have anything to
say about processing streams of data but
it turned out to be quite close to home
for people who like to use spark and and
now there's a variant of SPARC called
spark streaming that that is a little
more geared up to kind of processing
data as it arrives and you know sort of
breaks it up into smaller batches and
runs in a batch at a time to spark
so it's good for a lot of bad stuff but
that's certainly on to be thing right to
wrap up the UH you should view spark as
a kind of evolution after MapReduce and
I may fix some expressivity and
performance sort of problems or that
MapReduce has what a lot of what SPARC
is doing is making the data flow graph
explicit sort of he wants you to think
of computations in the style of figure
three of entire lineage graphs stages of
computation and the data moving between
these stages and it does optimizations
on this graph and failure recovery is
very much thinking about the lineage
graph as well so it's really part of a
larger move and big data processing
towards explicit thinking about the data
flow graphs as a way to describe
computations a lot of the specific win
and SPARC have to do with performance
part of the prepend these are
straightforward but nevertheless
important some of the performance comes
from leaving the data in memory between
transformations rather than you know
writing them to GFS and then reading
them back at the beginning of the next
transformation which you essentially
have to do with MapReduce and the other
is the ability to define these data sets
these are Dedes and tell SPARC to leave
this RDD in memory because I'm going to
reuse it again and subsequent stages and
it's cheaper to reuse it than it is to
recompute it and that sort of a thing
that's easy and SPARC and hard to get at
in MapReduce and the result is a system
that's extremely successful and
extremely widely used and if you deserve
real success okay that that's all I have
to say and I'm happy to take questions
if anyone has them
you